Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
says he's firing all regional military
enlistment officers after a nationwide
inspection authorities opened 112
criminal cases including bribery and
illegal border crossings or those who
want to keep their Army rank zielinski
says should go and fight Russian troops
on the front lines
we're dismissing all regional military
commissars the system should be run by
people who know exactly what war is and
why cynicism and bribery at a time of
war is high treason instead soldiers
who've been through the front line or
who can't be in the trenches because
they've lost their health lost their
limbs but have retained their dignity
and have no cynicism they can be
entrusted with this recruitment system
Al jazeera's correspondent stip varsen
is in the Northeast Ukrainian city of
hakive instead these are serious charges
but it's also a serious response from
zielinski isn't it
yes exactly we have actually been
investigating this case in the last
couple of weeks and we found out that
solenski definitely has a huge problem
here uh we spoke to a special
investigator and he told us about a real
system uh in the whole line of these
military recruitment agencies including
medical doctors drivers people all
involved in these schemes and basically
what happens is of course Ukraine needs
a lot of soldiers now a lot of people
are dying on the front line the
counter-offensive is not going as
planned but what happens is a lot of men
don't want to fight so they're bribing
these officials they're paying according
to this investigator up to three
thousand dollars to get a ticket a white
ticket so to say which is sort of a
medical certificate showing that they're
unfit to fight we also spoke to one of
the people who don't want to go to the
front line and he said it's not only
about bribery but there's also a lot of
other things wrong with this recruitment
of officials they're using Force they're
using all kinds of verbal abuse so there
is a whole system and zelensky is not
only battling this on the front line
against Russia but also internally
battling this corruption Nationwide
instead what more do we know about these
latest missile strikes on Ukraine
uh supersonic King jail missiles towards
the Western Airfield in the west of the
country one is intercepted above Kiev
and we know that some debris has fallen
on a children's hospital and a private
house there but also near this Airfield
there were residential areas hit an
eight-year-old boy got injured there and
he died later in hospital also we saw a
large strike in sapure last night where
a hotel where a lot of U.N humanitarian
workers often stay has been hit there
was also a children's camp going on in
that hotel but I was just finished when
this strike happened and the U.N
coordinates here in Kiev has really
condemned this attack she called it an
appalling attack and she really calls on
Russia to stop this indiscriminate
attacks as she called them against
Ukraine okay thank you so much that is
Step Vasan for us in hakeef